tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo su un chip che la
smetta di 20 ragazzi è un videogioco che
avevo provato il quale riesco a schivare
le pallottole c'e veramente pazzesco e
direi di iniziare a giocare perché
ancora se è bello la metà di quanto era
bella la demo che avevo provato la demo
sarà una bomba pazzesca ragazzi ve lo
dico io
matrix entrando in materia che cazzo
cazzo che figlio nick to connect lost
perfetto però non c'è internet come
cazzo mi connetto tutto un internet
vinto il mio zio muoviti con west i'm
with mouse
ok devono mirare col mouse ma chi è figo
no ragazzi alla lasme vi spiego come
funziona la prima io mi muovo il tempo
va normale times ma sto spiegando io
[ __ ] alla presente il tempo si muove
normalmente quando io mi muovo se io sto
fermo va tutto al rallenty ed è
bellissimo uccidi tutti non è così che
si usano le pistole o sbaglio no è mia
quella minchione ma se tu mi fatti la
pistola posso fotterti la mamma matrix
mi fa una pippa però qualche roba ma che
roba
ma chi spari [ __ ] fam
a proposito di mamme vabbè magari
proviamoci perché ho lanciato la pistola
invece di sparare un genio luca eccoli
head shot è già mamma ma donna che botta
non ci credo l'ho mancato piazza cori
coiana ma che non mi raggiunge la fa e
mi spiace che hai paura zio scusami pro
ti devo sparare in faccia o che peccato
madonna lega che di gioco ego e figo a
mi fa rivedere tutta la scena uno
bellissimo primo super hot e la navigata
dell'amalgama questo cos'è greg the gun
ratio del canto grazie molto gentile e
ti devo sparare scusami madonna che mira
di merola ciò regali devo sparare al
pirellino scusami zio mi spiace molto
che come si è piegato raccolta frate se
la prossima volta sparì senza colpire i
magari non sparare ormai bravo a posto
quando uscirà al gioco completo sono il
primo a giocà c'è ke kazzo fatto
disparate tra giorno ma [ __ ]
chiavi sparate tra di voi
oh mio dio questo è difficile otto
ragazzi o ragazze deciso senza valentino
guardalo guardalo madonna senza lamenti
lega
c'è va bene neanche ralenti ha bisogno
del ralenti quando si è fa di genere non
hai più colpi lancia la tua arma ma
[ __ ]
ok grazie molto gentile che questa
prendo io e sentite magari sparata
vostra nonna non ha mai grazie madonna
senso fa sta roba
ma porca [ __ ] ah no no no per chi vuole
ma va avanti grazie mille molto gentile
l'ho preso l'ho preso no e allora devi
capire crepare la tartaruga però so però
quando mi voglio sfogare gli ads found
out no va bene lo zio vorrei tanto
venire con voi che siete molto belli e
gentili però sta passando un treno e lo
stai perdendo grazie molto gentile
attento al treno molto bravo
per chi fa morire come corrono tumori
perfetto per milos tom anche stavo
riuscendo mancarlo e regala lo dico
merda no noe kat
non ci credo finiti i colpi e va bene
poi sono finiti colpire ma dai che cazzo
ma fango e una spada davvero ma sei
serio che figo chiesto raccogli tu con
gli altri no vabbè no vabbè tanto amici
ma cosa non è sto gioco ninja favi
stronzi fra le gambe sexies metto a
posto grazie molto sentire anche tempo
stesso inchieste volevo prendere lui in
realtà ha sbagliato livello è
impossibile ok
ok spinta sui maroni no su una mira di
merda merda
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye ok
ragioniamo fermi 1 è andato altro pure
si è fatta ho vinto ma c'è ancora vita
se mi ammazzi ok grazie a dio cioè una
mira di merda zio però ti voglio fare un
favore ti spara al piedi ecco ma se sei
una [ __ ] che cazzo ci questo rega è
stato veramente un casino lo devo dire
però va bene morpheus sarebbe fiero di
me 46 cosa che cazzo fai dai numeri
aiuto disconnected oddio che cazzo se no
va beh sono uscito dal matrix sono
ragazzi che sono tornato davvero prima
cosa ti è capitato tutti ricevono
qualcosa di diverso guarda mi è capitato
il gioco di peppa pig quindi peppa pig
al don non ho scritto aidone
torniamo su grazie del messaggio molto
gentile come quando ti chiama tua madre
quando stai finendo una partita online
non puoi mettere in pausa non guardano
nuovi livelli e me lo fa rifare da zero
get over it massa ci sono nuovi perfetto
superman
non lo so perché sto facendo così ce n'è
uno dietro è morto da solo
vabbè zio è morto mi dispiace non
pregare per lui prega per me
ecco a posto a ce n'è un altro ciao zio
sempre caso che è successo sto tizio non
è morto è morto lo so ma no non ci credo
ma chi ammira no raga ma neanche la non
lo prendo neanche se li lancio l'arma a
parte fare figure di merda posso
ucciderlo certo che anche tu sei messo
veramente lì ma che cazzo di andata ci
metterei degli occhiali perché cazzo non
ci vede in mezz'ora che mi spari dove
cazzo la presa ma [ __ ]
dai dai dai dai e lo sociale super rok
wrong place posto sbagliato al momento
sbagliato questo non è whisky questo
acquistino questa una tisana grazie zia
che adesso arrivano tutti quelli che
volevano luigi cazzo
era la colonna il mio vero obiettivo
ragazzi voi non lo sapete ma le colonne
sono cattive persone amaro montenegro
sapore vero camaro monte vero sapore
torniamo questa cosa perfetto questa
volta parte la testa a testa la testa ma
porca put o ma non è possibile ma qui
che cosa se posso servirlo de bondt e
alla pesca grazie signor prefetto
ragiona seller gradisce dal nesquik
grazie questo ha respinto un proiettile
con che poteri magici perché ti sto
whisky ma dai
ma dai perfetto intanto con la preso una
pistola sebbene [ __ ]
sì l'ho preso l'ho preso ho vinto no non
ho vinto il piatto vinto la madonna ho
preso quello dietro vabbè dai ci siamo
perfetto
qualcun altro no è perfetto grazie
questo succede ad andare nel bar di fa
vj al ronzone coyote training
l'allenamento guardia guardia mi sono
pisciato addosso [ __ ] basta queste
scritte non sto fermo madonna tease
prendo a schiaffi in faccia da un team
ub
e va bene il suo fermo non rompere il
cazzo però che mi hai fatto che c'è una
ciotola di un car ok ok ok ok 54 32 mi
chiama floor è tutto uno bravo cane
qualcosa bravo a chi cazzo stai dando
del cane ora non so mica tua madre
qualcuno mi spiega il senso disco
livello ma devi essere nuovo e tu devi
essere quello [ __ ] ciao zio come
stai a devo combattere perché sono
bellino con in gabbia che figo ragazzi
ho guardato troppo il royal rumble per
poter perdere una cosa del genere
la mazza da baseball pam cazzo ma che
pugno ma arriva che cazzo sei rambo ma
rava minchia tutti ma cos'è una partita
di baseball questa e non lo sapevo 13
sempre svecchiato golo dietro stress e
il quadro ha fatto male in giro dimmelo
mese fa male rifacciamo europa violenza
neanche wwe ragazzi ragazzi sta roba mi
gasa ogni secondo di più ve lo dico
lavoro non finito che senso ha sta
pigiando poverino che una finisci
tranquillo scusami nuvole non si piscia
così però si piscia collega non col
braccio con la gamba
ciao zio non sa pisciare gli diamo una
mano grazie ai su falla bene fa la bene
farla bene bravo esatto è così che si
piscia vieni a dargli una mano frate
vinitaly una mano che tu sai come si
piscia vero il figlio perfetto era
chiuso il bagno cazzo peccato ma che
cazzo cala madonna colta a zio tua vah
il fucile a pompa tua mamma ciao la
palla il fucile ok che botta in testa
bravo sì me lo dai me lo presti che mi
serve grazie grossi mille molto gentile
posso provare a vedere se funziona
cazzo funziona che bello adesso ci
divertiamo a 0
mamma fanno merda uniti colpi
senti giochiamo a biliardo zio inizio io
allora si serve così fermo un attimo
c'era la pistola merda fammi un favore
eliminati una pallina che vado a cercare
ok anche questo anche questo grazie
molto gentile mi terresti anche
quest'altra molto principe ghazi misto
scialando gasparovic breaking ciao zio
scusami se sono entrato dal soffitto ma
mi creda o tom cruise svoltasi io devo
sfracellarsi il malleolo scusami se te
lo faccio però e mi hanno detto di farlo
grazie mille
anche the frate bravo quello era
esattamente lì si trova il malleolo
perfetto shopping da un dio present
mamma sì ho preso qualche posizione da
figo ma sto [ __ ]
ciao ciao dice la mamma la mamma
perfetta su superò che sto facendo tra
l'altro salento e stanno cucinando la
met devastato un laboratorio di chimica
la stessa cosa volevo fare a scuola però
non me lo faceva fare danza cane ora che
non sono tua madre te lo ripeto va bene
che da insomma la musica a zio dove
cazzo stai
[Musica]
parliamo un po della tua famiglia parte
che sei un rincoglionito che non riesce
neanche a fregarmi prova bene abbastanza
bravo cane vabbè dai a posto
this connecting ancora che stordiscono
emanò ricavi stati scommettendo di nuovo
cazzo abbastanza per oggi io mi stavo
divertendo abbiamo guastafeste della
minkia ragazzi hanno detto basta per
oggi e io obbedisco e lascio che
continuiamo nel prossimo episodio cioè
allora la demo era veramente [ __ ] ma
veramente una bomba ma questo è una roba
fuori di voglio miliardi di like pro sta
roba da chiara ragazzi concludo che
l'episodio spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto è un mi piace se anche voi
pensate di essere cibo o proprio come me
con questa bella faccia
fatemi sapere se volete che la continui
a casa i ragazzi se il video è piaciuto
lasciato argomento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come di video trovate
una descrizione di più alla nota ancora
iscritto subscriber t e noi ci rivediamo
in un prossimo vinto dalle ragazze
[Musica]